[MUSIC]
As fun as that clip was to watch, it was ten times more fun to make.
We did a silent film because the Canvas is a visual-only medium that
doesn't provide sound.
When we were brainstorming this project, we had to figure out how to
do things typically done in video editing software, in the Canvas.
We accomplished this by using a combination of tutorials we found online,
source code, sometimes in other programming languages, that we converted to
JavaScript, and other times, a description of the thing that we wanted to do.
We don't have the time to teach you all of the effects we did, but
we'll give you some pointers in this lesson.
Check the instructor's notes for more details.